foreign
welcome back so today I'm going to give
a quick high-level review of Taylor
series from calculus this is one of the
most important Concepts in all of
calculus because it Bears on so many
different aspects that pop up in applied
math so essentially Taylor series is how
we can approximate a nasty function in
terms of a polynomial approximation or a
polynomial expansion okay and we're
going to use Taylor series a lot in
things like deriving the solutions of
differential equations and a lot of our
favorite special functions like the
exponential the logarithm Sines and
cosines you can almost think of those as
the solutions of special important
differential equations that come up all
the time and we can derive them through
their Taylor series so this is a review
very very important concept for you to
understand
so I'm going to explain this actually
probably three or four ways and then I'm
going to fire up uh Python and Matlab
and show you some plots to really build
your geometric intuition for the Taylor
series
so
if you start with a function that we're
going to try to approximate so a
function f of x we're going to say that
we have some function f and we're going
to approximate f of x plus Delta X so
we're going to perturb uh the
independent variable a little bit by
Delta X and we're going to tailor expand
it in this variable X so we're going to
say a function f of x
Maybe Taylor expanded
may be
Taylor expanded
and I'm going to revisit all these and
explain what I mean this function can be
Taylor expanded about
a base point
X so this base point x and this is
assuming that my function is relatively
smooth like it's not um we're assuming
that our function you know f of x is
smooth and is not you know cuspy because
if my function has a cusp or or a
discontinuity then the derivatives are
not going to exist or be matched at this
point and so this isn't going to work so
a function f can be Taylor expanded
about a base point you know if f is
smooth
at X meaning all of its derivatives
exist and are continuous that's what
smooth means to mathematicians and
specifically we're going to say I'm
going to write this in pink
we're going to say that f of x plus
Delta X
is going to equal so we're kind of
assuming that Delta X is small this
doesn't have to be small we could have
large Delta X depending on the radius of
convergence of the series I'm about to
write out but in my mind I often think
of Delta X as kind of you know close by
it's a small little Point close to X and
so f of x plus Delta X is first off the
best of the the first approximation to
this would be that well okay it's just f
of x
and then the next correction term would
be
plus DF DX this is the derivative of f
with respect to X evaluated at my base
point x
times Delta X okay this is my like first
order correction
plus the second derivative D Squared f d
x squared evaluated at x times Delta x
squared and this is going to be
um
divided by 2 factorial
plus d cubed F over DX cubed times Delta
X cubed over 3 factorial plus dot dot
dot forever and ever and ever
um you know plus dot dot dot plus d the
nth derivative of f with respect to X
Delta x to the N Over N factorial plus
dot dot and this is going to go on
forever and ever and ever that's what
the Taylor series does is
um is essentially you know this is an
exact expression it might function is
smooth and all of its derivatives exist
and are continuous at that base point x
then I can basically expand out uh this
function at nearby points in terms of
this infinite sum of all of these
derivatives
it's on calculus so I'm not going to go
through all of the properties and derive
this from scratch I'm showing you what
it is I'm reminding you what it is we're
going to actually plot this
approximation for a function like sine
of X or cosine of x in in Matlab and in
Python
and again I you know kind of uh from a
numerical perspective I like to think
about this often as Delta X is a small
perturbation for my base point x and so
I might not want to actually compute all
of these terms I might want to chop this
off you know at first order at just you
know my linear Delta X term or its
second order at my first you know my
Delta x squared term and I want to know
how good that approximation is if I chop
this thing off if I approximate this at
some finite you know finite expansion n
and so you'll see if Delta X is small
then each of these terms should get
smaller and smaller and smaller right
like Delta x squared is smaller than
Delta X let's say Delta X is like 0.1
then this is 0.01 this is 0.001 you know
these get smaller and smaller and
smaller and so this approximation should
get better and better and better the
more terms I add so even numerically if
I want to approximate this function I
might only need to add up the first few
terms in this series but if I add up all
of the terms this is exactly true this
is the Taylor series expansion okay and
this is in fact
in fact in uh maybe I'll draw a little
picture of this so again
um you know remember
I was drawing this function f of x and I
said it was continuous let's say this is
my base point x and this is X Plus Delta
X
then this Taylor series expansion is
valid and it holds for any Delta X until
I hit a point where my derivatives are
discontinuous so this Taylor series
expansion is valid for this large we
call this the radius of convergence this
will converge until I hit a
discontinuity or a cusp or somewhere
where these derivatives are not smooth
and don't exist so you can actually do
this for big Delta X as long as you keep
all of the infinite terms in this series
if you want to approximate this then
your Delta X better be small
good so that's a Taylor series
um there are alternate ways of writing
this so sometimes I'll write it like
this when we're doing numerical
approximations
uh sometimes I'm going to write it in
the other way which is
um
I'll say or
f
of X could be expanded
about a totally different base point
about a point
uh look let's call it a so what happens
if I expand this about some other point
then I'm going to say
um
f of x
is going to equal F of a plus my
derivative of f with respect to X
evaluated at a times
x minus a
plus I'm going to and then I'll talk you
through what this what this means the
second derivative of f with respect to X
evaluated at a times x minus a squared
over 2 factorial
plus the third derivative and so on and
so forth forever this is x squared x
cubed
x minus a cubed over 3 factorial plus
dot dot dot and
actually what we're saying here these
are just different ways of writing the
exact same thing
so if I have
um where do I want to write this so if I
have
some point a
and I have some point
then this
x minus a is playing the same role as my
Delta X was up here okay so you can just
literally say X
equals
a plus Delta X okay so this is kind of
the exact same uh the exact same
expression so you can you can um what am
I trying to say
I can pick some point a
and then for any other point x and
whatever X is I can write down f of x in
terms of a and all of its derivatives A
F of a f Prime of a f double Prime of a
f triple prime of a and so on I can
write down f of x in terms of just the
information I have at this point as long
as my function is smooth or if I like to
think of this as a small perturbation a
small Delta X I can also think of it
that way so these are two completely
equivalent ways of writing these and I
think this actually would be good
exercise for you is to kind of you know
write these both out and convince
yourself that these are in fact
identical to each other if you write
down kind of this relationship here
good so now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to actually do this for an example
of a sine function and a cosine function
and then we're going to plot these in
Python and Matlab good
good so I'm actually going to use this
formula for my example of f of x equals
sine of x
example f of x equals
sine of X and we're going to use the
base point a equals zero so this is
actually a special case of the Taylor
series called the maclaurin series this
is the McLaren how do I spell maclaurin
Mac
uh black Lauren series
if the base point a equals zero and
that's very very common because you'll
find that it's going to be really easy
to evaluate these derivatives at a
equals zero okay so we can literally
write this down this is super easy
um f of x
is going to equal F of zero
plus F Prime
of zero times x and again x minus a when
a is zero is really easy so that's F
Prime at zero times x
plus F double Prime at 0 divided by 2
factorial times x squared plus F triple
prime at 0 divided by three factorial X
cubed and how many do I want to write
I'll probably go up to fifth order um
just because this is uh important to see
what happens the fourth derivative of 0
over 4 factorial x to the fourth power
plus the fifth derivative sometimes you
put these in parentheses like that the
fifth derivative of F at 0 over 5
factorial x to the fifth plus dot dot
this never ends this goes on forever and
ever and ever this is only exact this is
literally you know sine of x is only
equal to this if I add all of these
terms up add infinitum I'm just stopping
at five because I can't yeah I'm not
infinite okay good
and so I literally take f of x and
evaluate it at zero so sine of zero okay
this is
um
sine of zero
Plus what's the first derivative of sine
it's cosine so that's cosine
zero times x
plus now what's the second derivative
the derivative of cosine is now minus
sine so
this is minus
sine evaluated at 0 over 2 factorial x
squared now the third derivative of sine
is minus cosine so minus cosine of 0
over 3 factorial that's a three
x cubed the fourth derivative comes back
to A positive plus sign
of 0 over 4 factorial x to the fourth uh
plus cosine plus minus plus cosine of
zero over five factorial x to the fifth
plus not the time you see the pattern is
I have you know signs for the even
powers and I have cosines for the odd
powers and the sign flips because I take
the derivative of sine the first
derivative is cosine the second
derivative is negative sign that
negative cosine and positive sine and it
repeats every four okay and and this is
the last step evaluating sine of zero
and cosine of 0 is super easy sine of 0
is 0 cosine of zero is one
and so now we find our uh our series is
you know zero plus 1 times x
minus 0 x squared
minus you know cos is one that's one
over three factorial X cubed plus sine
of zero zero so I don't have any even
terms
plus cosine of zero is one one over five
factorial x to the fifth uh dot dot dot
dot you know plus forever so what you
see here is all of the even powers of X
are zero because sine of zero is zero
and I only get these odd Powers because
cosine of zero is one and the sign will
alternate so I can even write this down
you know I know this is going to be x
minus X cubed over three factorial plus
x to the fifth over five factorial minus
x to the seventh over seven factorial
plus x to the ninth I know the pattern
so I can keep doing this forever and
ever and this is
my Taylor series expansion
or technically my maclaurin expansion
for sine of x
and it is odd so this is actually really
comforting because we know that uh the
sine function if I actually literally
draw a sine of x
it is an odd function like that meaning
um you know has this kind of this kind
of mirror symmetry if I take sine of
minus X it is minus sine of X and so I
can only achieve that with these odd
Powers it's literally an odd function so
it's cool and reassuring that the Taylor
series all of the odd terms are the only
ones that stick around good
okay that sign I'm going to do the same
thing for cosine and then I'm going to
do Python and Matlab okay so let's do
the same thing uh now for cosine so
example
what is f of x equals cos
X when I'm a chlorine expand it same
exact thing it's going to be F 0 plus F
Prime 0 X Plus F double Prime 0 over 2
factorial x squared and so on and so I'm
going to get you know cosine X
equals
cosine of zero
plus the derivative of cosine
at zeros you know minus
sine of zero
times x
plus the second derivative of cosine at
zero which is again minus cosine
zero divided by 2 factorial
times x squared
plus the third derivative of cosine
which I believe is now going to be a
plus sign plus sine of zero over 3
factorial X cubed plus the fourth
derivative which is plus cosine of 0
over 4 factorial x to the fourth plus
now the fifth derivative is again A
minus sine zero over five factorial x to
the fifth uh minus and I'm just I'm
writing this down because you can almost
Intuit what the answer is going to be
from the pattern uh minus COS of zero
over six factorial x to the sixth plus
dot dot dot forever and ever and ever
and so again
the only terms here all of now the odd
terms are going to be zero because those
are the ones that have signs so sine of
zero is always zero so zero zero zero
and the only terms left are these ones
that have a cosine
um
of zero because cosine of zero is one
and so this equals now one
minus one over two factorial x squared
plus one over four factorial x to the
fourth minus one over six factorial x to
the sixth and of course you can just
write this down forever and ever one
over eight factorial x to the eighth
plus dot dot dot and again because
cosine
is an even function
meaning that cosine of negative x equals
cosine of x I can only achieve this with
the even powers in the Taylor series
expansion so this is just a double check
of our intuition because cosine is an
even function it can only have these
even powers of x
okay good so really easy to compute the
Taylor series or the maclaurin series
for our functions that we we are you
know interested in that we know and love
you'll notice
that the sine and the cosine terms
almost have all of the terms from the
exponential e to the X and so we'll show
in the next lecture that if you take uh
you know e to the X you can actually
break it down into its sine components
and its cosine components that's very
important that's called Euler's formula
but for now I'm just going to pick this
sine of x expression and we're actually
going to plot this in Matlab we're going
and python we're literally going to show
that if I only have the first order
approximation it'll be this linear
approximation and then if I add the next
term this cubic I'll get a slightly I'll
get a slightly better cubic
approximation and when I add the fifth
I'll get a slightly better fit
approximation and we'll just add this up
and show that this really does
approximate my function as I add more
and more terms I'm going to erase this
and then that's what we're going to do
okay so I moved my equation up here so I
have a little bit of breathing room and
I'm going to do this in Matlab and in
Python so I think I'm just going to
start with Matlab this is the code I
wrote It's probably 10 plus years ago to
demonstrate this concept okay so
essentially what I'm going to do is I'm
literally going to approximate sine of x
using the first order term the linear
term X the cubic term X cubed the fifth
order quintic term the septic term the
nonic term I think those are cool names
uh cubic quintix septic nonic I don't
know what's after that if you do please
tell me
um and so essentially I'm just going to
walk you through this code I'm not going
to write it from scratch you can
download this the first block of code
here from lines one to six
all it does is it just plots my function
my sine function from x equals negative
10 to x equals plus 10. and I've called
this y when in reality I really should
have called this f of x I wonder how
many y's I have I wonder if this is
going to butcher everything if I do
y equals F let's see
nope that's going to mess everything up
okay well you all are very bright and
you can uh you'll be okay with the fact
that now we've just renamed this we're
calling this uh
y of X okay we're calling this
y of x
good so the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm just going to plot my function y
of X that's going to be the ground truth
and then we're going to compare the
linear the cubic the fifth the seventh
the ninth order approximations
so first things first let's just
run this
and I'll make this a little bit bigger
okay
sorry my axes are also small
um this is you know time and this is uh
sorry this is X and this is y of X my
sine function and it looks like you
would expect it uh expect it to look
and now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to compute my first order Taylor
series approximation which the way you
do this in Matlab is you can create a
polynomial this basically P equals 1 0
means that you have a polynomial 1 in
The X to the one and zero in the X to
the zero so it's literally X plus zero
and polyval of P comma X evaluates that
polynomial with those coefficients on
this data Vector X and that returns my
FIT y
so here now I can plot uh this one on
top of it
and you can see this is literally my
linear fit my just the first term my
first polynomial approximation and it's
actually not terrible like it's
obviously terrible out here but it's not
so terrible for a small region around
the origin for a small X near zero it's
not too bad
maybe I can make my uh set GCF font
size 14 does that make it better nope
GCA font size
there you go let's make it 24 just to
make everything a little easier okay I
should have done this easier yeah sooner
now you can see all of the plot axes
that starts at you know at x equals zero
this thing looks pretty good
but what happens when I do a a higher
order polynomial so now what we're going
to do is we're going to do a third order
Taylor series approximation so again
that polynomial has coefficients and it
goes in order from biggest power to
smallest power so this one should have a
minus one over three factorial in the X
cubed a 0 in the x squared a 1 in The X
and a zero in the ones this is literally
one minus one third one over three
factorial X cubed plus X plus zero I'm
going to evaluate my polynomial with
polyval on X and I'm going to plot this
y Taylor series 3.
oh let's see if that works
okay and now you can see uh maybe I'll
make all of my line widths a little bit
bigger so I'll make these you know make
this one like five and I'll make all of
my 1.2s equal to two
uh replace replace replace replace
replace
this will be a little nicer
make my font size big again
okay good so now
um everything is a little bit cleaner I
have my third order polynomial here and
you can see that again uh for small X
for X near zero it's actually really
good and it's slightly better than
linear so it's very hard for me to do
this uh mirror but you can see that it's
actually getting a little bit better of
an approximation of that first turn in
the sine function so the cubic
approximation is a little bit better
than linear
uh and then similarly I can add a fifth
order polynomial now I'm just making a
bigger polynomial that has this fifth
order term so that's one over factorial
five and the X to the fifth place zero
in the X to the fourth and so on and so
forth so this is my fifth order
polynomial
again in purple now you know my fifth of
her polynomial is doing even better it's
uh it's capturing even more of these
kind of bends or camel humps uh and I
think in this script I go up to uh ninth
order so I'll just actually do all of
that and then I'll pop in uh do I have a
legend I seem to be completely missing a
legend here
um but you can see let's let's just do
Legend
um sine X you know X cubed cubic
uh quintic
septic and nonic
and maybe I'll call X linear
is that going to work that's going to
work okay so this is kind of the the
outcome so you see that every term that
you include gets better and better and
better it kind of expands this radius of
how accurate your Taylor series
approximation is now clearly you know at
very very far distances polynomials are
a terrible approximation to sign you
know out at x equals 100 and X equals
minus 100 I would need a huge amount
of this series to fit that function you
know for very very large x but at least
for reasonably small X this is getting
better and better and more and more
accurate so this really does do a good
job of approximating these functions uh
through this Taylor series approximation
okay if you really want to do
approximate a sine function you should
use a Fourier transform not a Taylor
series you should use a Fourier series
and that'll be a whole you know set of
lectures later on good okay now I'm just
going to swap this out and do the same
thing in Python
okay so we are trying to show that this
uh Taylor series technically it's a
maclaurin series because it's based it
at zero this uh series approximation for
sine of x in terms of polynomials of X
actually does an increasingly good job
of approximating that function so this
is a code written by Alan captanaglu
based on one of my Matlab codes this is
in Python and so I'm just going to walk
you through what happens if we only use
the linear approximation for sine or
only the linear plus cubic or linear
plus cubic plus quintic and in this case
we have our linear cubic quintix septic
and nonic term so you know but but you
can go higher and higher you can add
11th and 13th and 15th and 17th terms as
high as you like and what we're going to
show is that this Pro this approximation
gets better and better the more terms
you add
okay so to do this in Python uh you have
to import some stuff early on you have
to import numpy and matplotlib and uh
things like that this factorial function
so you can do factorials so let's
do that
um and then this is essentially what
this code is doing the first block here
is just creating our sine function so
we're saying y of x equals sine of X and
that's going to be the ground truth
we're going to compute sine of x on a
domain x equals minus 10 to 10 and we're
going to plot it and then we're going to
plot the linear the cubic the quintic on
top of that to see if they get better
and better and better okay so the first
or order Taylor expansion
essentially what we're going to do is
we're going to define the coefficients
of our polynomial so this goes from
biggest term to smallest term this is
the X to the one power and x to the zero
power so this P equals 1 0 literally
means I have one of X Plus 0 of x to the
0 of 1. and then
um I'm going to evaluate that polynomial
on this kind of X Vector so X is a you
know a bunch of points from negative 10
to 10 and I'm going to evaluate my
polynomial on that that Vector to get my
linear fit which is in this variable y
T1 and we're going to plot it
similarly we're going to do our third
order Taylor series approximation which
is going to be again this polynomial is
minus 1 over 3 factorial in the X to the
3 spot plus zero in the x squared spot
plus one and the X to the one spot plus
zero in the X to the zero spot that's
this polynomial we're going to evaluate
that polynomial on our data X to get
this y T3 which is my third order Taylor
series approximation by cubic we're
going to plot that and we're going to do
that for fifth for seventh and for ninth
order
and so if I do this and then we're gonna
we're gonna plot it so let's see if I
can do this
and Alan added in these Legends here
sine of x first order second third order
fifth order seventh order and so on and
so you can see so this uh this yellow
curve here is our linear fit and it's
actually not terrible so you know very
close to the origin to x equals zero
it's actually not that bad but for far
away you know very quickly it stops it
doesn't capture for example when sine
turns over when it kind of uh you know
switches directions and my cubic
function which I believe is this uh kind
of light blue cyan one the cubic
function is doing a little bit better
it's starting to capture when sine kind
of turns around the fifth order function
in purple here does even better still
and then every term you add when you add
the seventh and the ninth and so on and
so forth it gets a little bit better a
little bit more of that function now
clearly this is going to do a pretty
poor job for a very very large x you
know x equals positive 100 or negative
100 I'm going to need a ton of terms in
this Taylor series to do a good job
but the cool thing about this math this
kind of calculus is because this is a
smooth function and all of the
derivatives exist if I really did add up
all of these infinitely many polynomials
it actually would perfectly approximate
sine of x at any point x I like even
very very far away okay but for
numerical approximation you can see that
adding more terms actually does kind of
improve the accuracy and the Fidelity
for a growing radius okay good and of
course we're using these to solve and
approximate differential equations I
think that's all I wanted to show you
today so stay tuned for the next lecture
thank you